you
we have one more speaker
I'm very excited to introduce to you and
that is Albert Greenberg Albert is a
corporate vice president at Microsoft
he's in the Azure networking group which
is the team that develops engineers and
runs all of the systems and tools that
power the Microsoft cloud network he is
well known as an author and a researcher
himself multiple awards including his
signet ryx test a time award he's a
veteran of both Bell Labs and AT&T where
he was a principal in developing a lot
of the systems and tools that AT&T used
to run its network and has done
foundational work in developing the
architectures and systems that are part
of Software Defined Networking so Albert
joined us in 2007 he joined the Azure
team you joined say Microsoft Research
in 2007 he joined the Azure team in 2010
and he's here with us tonight and so
with that thank you for joining Albert
Greenberg thank you hi so it's a
pleasure to talk to you about startups I
the startup that we're on is doubling
every year it's and it's an amazing
journey and it by the way and thank you
for coming just you know we you'll see
that I hope you know I see a lot of
faces that I recognize in the in the
audience and you know we have a
beautiful new space you'll find that
we're we're open and I'd like to see you
more often than just in this room and
and hopefully spend more time with you
so I'm going to try and describe the
challenge of building a cloud and and
the expectations that we have for the
cloud is it really exciting to be on
this journey to build the cloud we see
it as the platform for all the world's
computing it's a very inspiring task to
build and we see so much workload
pouring on it mission critical workloads
Patel's police forces I mean
just you know interacting with with
groups like that where they take
reliabilities super seriously inspires
us to even take it more seriously and
understand what they mean by reliability
and in embody that in our DNA so I'm
gonna talk about reliability and I
convince you I hope that reliability is
the coolest thing that you could work on
let's see if that go okay so one thing
that you know at Microsoft we do and I
do in every one of my staff meetings and
every one of our you know technical
meetings is you know talk about not just
deep tech but deep culture so and I'm
gonna do that here and and I'm not gonna
bury it at the end I want to talk about
culture on the first slide so do a
little bit of that then I'll talk about
the open platform we're building for the
research community and then you know
give you some view of what Azure scale
means and what it means to build
mission-critical applications for for
all a mission-critical platform for all
applications on the planet and how we
that causes us to rethink things in
networking and what it you know amazing
opportunity we have to rethink and
rebuild networks and I'll just pick two
things
I'll pick how we rethink device firmware
and how we rethink design and operations
okay so you know let me talk a little
bit about culture again we take it super
seriously and we talk about it all the
time and you know the connection to
reliability is clear that you know
monocultures are risky right
monocultures people believe and you know
the same vision and they agree with each
other and they get it wrong and I've
seen it again and again and diversity in
in our team delivers creativity
innovation and lowers risk so yeah I
talk about diversity all the time just
to give you you know we have a long ways
to go it you know in our industry but
also you know I encourage enough okis on
it and so for example we we just
when we when we spin up new teams and
new initiatives we'd set as a target 40%
diverse hires and we hit it so we can do
it and and it's great it's working out
for us we're not there yet we're trying
to get better but update brought me back
in I should have given you a little bit
of priam before showing the video that
was a video of an intern we have now and
an intern it's it's I think I saw her in
the room that they created the emulator
that I'll tell you about so one thing
that we want to do is encourage you to
send us encourage you to collaborate
with us work with us and continue to
send us interns I can tell you you know
in my team alone we're hiring ninety
nine zero college hires that's our
target in the US and and more in other
places around the world okay so you know
we've spent just 7.5 billion recently
for a company called github we are
committed to open source and this is
just the what we call the nascar diagram
of the different open source projects we
have when I was glad to see data bricks
data bricks is one of the the customers
and they are also based on an open
source project so we are it's the new
Microsoft we're open we love Linux we
love open source and I think the github
acquisition speaks 7.5 billion times so
one thing I want to announce he
today it really is the the open-sourcing
a emulator that I'll tell you about
called the one that open networking open
network emulator one and it will be
available it's a little bit of a pre
announced it'll be available January
and I'll tell you about what it provides
for you and I hope it'll excite you
it'll provide you a way to really
emulate cloud scale and I'll tell you
what I mean by emulation in a minute and
it provides hands-on experience for
students on the real router software I'm
talking about thousands of routers and
switches real networks and create
large-scale labs on demand test your
your your next research idea and I mean
go as deep as you want in building
networks and they're the real networks
but you don't have to buy the hardware
you can run all this stuff on the cloud
our cloud so and this emulator supports
both commercial you know the normal sort
of sets of companies that you think of
in networking and our own open-source
switch firmware called Sonic and it uses
these are the word virtuals in here it's
really it's the real thing it's not
modeling or something like that it's the
it's the actual software that runs on
the device
and it'll be available in the
marketplace just you know start at
portal Dodger calm and you'll find it
and there's the contact by the way I'm
Albert at research no I'm Albert at
Microsoft comm excuse me and the you can
you can email me for other other things
okay so let me tell you a little bit as
your scale mark russinovich may have
gone through some of this what it means
these numbers I have to update all the
time because if we keep growing I think
you know the left the the bottom of
Africa we just added some new data
centers and regions
we're in 54 Azure region's we're all
over the earth
we've deployed 70,000 miles of fiber and
103 locations we have 130 global edge
sites these are out of the the Outer
Ring close to the metros where we can
reach the the rest of the internet and
just a sort of a fun fact that we think
that we are such a large network we we
deploy more more technology than than
any telco you can think of and probably
any cloud you can think of so we we
deployed more for example hundred G
dense wavelength-division multiplexing
links this year than the rest of the
industry combined so we are building a
huge network areas of innovation one
that I'll talk about today is we take an
algorithm and data driven approach to
network design and operations and it's
deep it's not us you know modeling on
the side it's in the guts and the the
actual mechanism how we run and design
the network and we innovate an optical
technology this thing would have been
cost prohibitive if we had just used
off-the-shelf technology and we innovate
in our own software-defined network it's
nice you know I hope some of you or your
interns get a chance to visit one of our
data centers just to get an idea of the
scale it's you know it's incredible
scale so like there's Dave malts in that
little car down there with the circle
around it just kidding but that I mean
that's that's the scale thing there and
there's the the big the you know the big
data center it's enormous scale and
that's just one of the data centers in
the region in terms of mission-critical
again I'm gonna talk to you about
reliability we we support
90 percent of the fortune 500 on the
Microsoft cloud these are just some of
the names but you know it it just you
know brings home that reliability is so
key it's you know these these people
haven't just taken their their small
test labs or something like that put it
in the cloud they put them their core
bill
in the cloud because it doesn't make
sense to build it on Prem and they
support the lot of things are born in
the cloud and other things are connected
to the to the premise but this is the
this is how these companies build and
run their their world and it's how you
know again the the critical government
and medical infrastructure runs the
world right so we connect to a lot of we
have a private connectivity offer that
is taking off like crazy where you you
know you want to have one relationship
with Microsoft with different access
providers these are some of the access
providers where you can get private
connectivity straight to the Microsoft
cloud and this this chart is also
growing so we can we reach everybody
with high speed privately and over
internet you know this is just a
something I often show and we believe in
in Azure you know what is what is the
hierarchy of needs for the cloud you
know what are the basic things and you
know it's all about you know at the
bottom you have to be secure if you're
not secure then it you know you won't
trust running your your critical apps in
the cloud so that's the that's at the
very bottom and we spend a lot of time
on security constantly reliability is
the one we'll talk about today it has to
be supportable you have to be able to I
mean just use it and it has to just work
without a lot of thinking and trying to
figure it out calling us up and it has
to work the way you expect it and it has
to be fast so those are my my priorities
and I'll in this talk talk about
reliability
and I'll talk about just to there's a
wide set of work on reliability but I'll
talk about the device firmware and talk
about sonic and which is on github and
I'll talk about the network emulator
also on github will be on github for you
to download okay so let me start with
Sonic so if you think about you know the
world of networks it's it's it's it's
changing in a very exciting way so you
know it had been that you'd buy this
monolithic box from a networking Avenger
and all the things that I highlight here
in blue you you would not have you you
really want to run your network and
consume your software the way you do
cloud and other computing artifacts you
don't want a big rip riot or a box that
you can't change and grow so you want
agility you want to be able to like we
in the cloud we ship weekly when there's
a bug we take care of the bug right away
you know but within you know hours or as
fast as we can roll it out a bug fix it
has to be serviceable this is something
that I don't know if academia studies
enough serviceability it's so critical
you have to be able to update and it
goes with reliability and and and the
velocity you have to be able to update
without anybody noticing you have to be
able to update all the time things have
to be modular so you can do these
hitless upgrades and restarts and it has
to be as simple as a you know use a you
know a normal sort of container update
to reload the OS image it has to be
something you can already do and
reliable up which I've talked about so
you know to two things here one is the
we're getting a lot of help from the
industry so there are these companies
that are producing amazing merchants
silicon these are Asics that you know
are fairly cheap and and can do
everything you'd like to do in
networking they have super high speed
they have lots of ports they have the
right kind of buffering they have you
know incredible capabilities hidden you
may not know about them but the ASIC
supports them and if you can just get
access to that ASIC and at the same time
do you want to protect you know you want
to protect your software that runs above
that ASIC so you need some sort of
hardware abstraction layer that allows
you to plug in any ASIC below your
software keeps working and but you can
still get to the unique features of the
the ASIC below and we have something
called switch abstraction interface
which provides that and I'll tell you
it's really working out so we can we
don't have to go with just one basic
vendor we can go with several it
provides it's again open source the go
to github pick it up it's it's open
source it's supported through the Open
Compute platform provides essentially
the dot H files for your your code
common api's which are then implemented
by drivers beneath it depending on the
ASIC it supports disaggregation you
don't have to buy this monolith you can
get the ASIC by the board you know get
the whole thing manufactured and build
your own router and so the software and
hardware it can evolve independently and
there's an open community around it so
above above this side we have something
which was you know definitely named in a
different way so you would remember it
called Sonic and that's the software
that really operates the switch and
that's what we use in Azure so it's also
available through OCP it provides
everything you need in terms of
functionality it's
I'll tell you a little bit more but it
really allows you to run you know your
your network devices like you'd run a
cloud service like you like you'd run
software in general yet you can do
networking so it's I mean it really
opens up the world to be able to change
things and give it the power of these
Asics and really enjoy the
disaggregation that the industry is
providing so you know here you know just
this is just a a the kind of network we
build and to support our regional
networks well it's a DES class style
network classes of Bell Labs
mathematician in the 50s it figured this
stuff out and and did a good job and so
there's a lot of regularity here a lot
of power here so it's like raid for
networks you have lots of components
things can fail it's okay because you've
got more things that are working yet you
can have a full bisection bandwidth you
basically can go from any point in a
region to any other point without
congestion and that you know you need
software running on those switches and
that's where we run sonic so there's it
shows it the Sonics was software there
now I mean one test of you know it
really is
you're really managing your software
like you would manage your your networks
offer like you'd manage software
services just stuff works that you'd
expect to work like down at the bottom
there's Redis DB you know it could be
any kind of caching service you want and
you know so in networking the very
simplest things like getting counters
out of a box in you know the old school
world there's this protocol called SNMP
back in the day 20 years ago when it was
invented it was awesome
but now every time you want a single
column and SNMP the ITF meets maybe they
don't accept it maybe they do maybe you
beg your vendor to get it in maybe they
do
they don't it's just counters I mean
what's the big deal so you you can just
you know reflect you can put a Redis
agent on the switch and it can just
fakes export whatever counters you need
and push pull all those options are
yours so you know then you know there's
the typical networking applications on
top of the operating system as well as
orchestration software and telemetry
software ansible which we use puppet
chef and so forth so we how does it
relate to we wouldn't do this project if
it didn't improve reliability so today
we we don't have control if we go to a
commercial vendor we're we're convincing
we're building in the world's biggest
cloud we we have big pockets we pocket
you know wallets or something but not we
don't we don't we can't control the
quality of what goes in that software
sonic gives us that control and then
really you know it's still hard work
software is hard but we don't support
every feature we just support what's
needed for the cloud applications so we
we minimize the baggage that goes along
and and then you know we're free to pick
and choose cherry-pick like what
software you want to go with and every
cloud provider that that consumes sonic
and every one of you if you consume
Sonic and pick your software hitlers
upgrade is huge for us we want to be
able if there's a bug take care of it if
there's a feature we want take care of
it without you as a customer noticing so
we can fix bugs and and do fleet wide
security patches and ours and new
features and days and yeah we put the
the pressure of the entire cloud on the
software so it's battle-tested
open-source so it's working out as I
said we have a lot of community we spend
time on community in the top right hand
corner or some of the companies that
that are also heavily invested in Sonic
we we work with the other companies too
to run their software in the sonic
framework and you know some some of the
and the middle-right
my right companies that do the the ODM
world they build the devices that that
that make the make up the hardware the
switch as well as on the on the left
middle the OEM world some of them anyway
like vista that they'd build a device
with and sell it directly and then below
you know we have all those basic
manufacturers and cisco as well all part
of the community so you know really it's
an invitation to you if you if you if
you like networking you want to or you
you think you might like networking you
want to experiment networking you can
consume sonic it's it's very pleasant I
think it's containerized docker and it's
familiar its Linux it's it's what you
know how to do you can just consume it
and make it work so try it and you can
you can find it by web search or you can
just you know remember this github URL
so I'm gonna train change now from we
did this network firmware because we
wanted greater control we wanted to
improve reliability and we want to take
care of all the bugs themselves we
didn't want we wanted just the features
we needed to improve reliability but
let's now you know think about the big
network let's think you know how do we
build a a network that is in a reliable
by design and and meet these goals
changes work as intended its resilient
we minimize the impact of changes it
learns and adapts automatically and we
can verify with formal methods any gap
between what we intend
network to do and what it actually does
and you saw all those links there right
there could be little defects in the
optics we have to be able to detect
those little defects
needle-in-a-haystack type problems where
we use machine learning so we have you
know a set of projects in a set of
collaborations with with Microsoft
Research in fact all this stuff that
I've talked about was either born in or
worked we work together with Microsoft
Research to bring to a sure and I will
talk about the top one and maybe the
second one but email me again it's
Albert at Microsoft comm and I can give
you the pointers to all the others so
and this is another you know slide about
some of the challenges that we face
you know we we if we need a fiber
nowadays or we need more capacity
between two points we we designed that
whole thing we run a boat we pull the
fiber across the ocean that our team
does that so we we take on that it's
about like about as routine as you I
take you know plug in an ethernet cable
we run the boat pull the fiber and we're
we're ready but we we have to be
resilient to storms typhoons you know
that the fiber somehow gets the Sharks
excited and they they like to bite the
fiber there's repeaters down there sadly
there's fishing that catches the cables
and there's potentially sabotage so we
you know it it costs a lot of money to
run the boat out to pull the fiber up
fix it and sink it back down so we we
think a lot about optimizing for
resilient designs so that we don't have
to rush the boat out we have enough
fiber in the right places that it's okay
if some some of these disasters happen
and netsim is one of the projects that
allows us to understand the impact of
any failure on the fiber a
okay so um let me tell you about that a
little bit and then I'll get on to the
one network emulator so one one theme
that I want to convey is a lot of the
stuff we do in networking to make the
network reliable is stuff that you
cannot do without a cloud and we the
amount of hours and the computational
methods we apply our cloud methods and
we need VM hours to do this so we we
simulate these are modeling like math
models simulations of the network
covering you know literally millions of
contingencies for every every fiber of
things that could go wrong and there's a
pipeline here and time lines so you know
think about if you use Azure you're
running as your batch every time you
think of a project and you you you
pretty much and this is what the cloud
job is all about you try to anticipate
all the things that could possibly go
wrong
get that risk into the model and then
simulate all these things and see see if
you're resilient to them and that's
that's just routine for us we run these
simulations before we touch the network
and before and as we design the network
and you know here's an example we we
created a fiber it's a fiber path with
partners and it's a bit unusual that it
lands in Spain most of them land north
north of Spain but we it was it was um
we want diversity so we land in Spain
and so we run it from the Virginia DC
area into Spain and just in this case we
we had to think about as we designed
this thing thousands of different
possible combinations of ways to design
and protect the the fibre and minimize
disruption as well as we as we went and
for that we did we Randy the netsim
simulator so there's lots of cool videos
on on the net that you can look for
Barea cable and you'll see
different government officials and
Microsoft officials talking about this
cable and if your if you you can also
find deep technical talks from my team
on how we built this cable now now I'm
going to talk to you about you know the
kind of work that I'm gonna it's more
detailed work the kind of work that
happens day-to-day and operating the
network and it's not a bad analogy to
think about you know flying a
interesting plane so they accept you
know your while the plane is flying
you're changing the plane and you're
adding engines and taking away engines
and the wings and wheels are changing
and so forth so it's a it's a evolving
plane in flight and but the consequence
is again the reliability has got to be
there the reliability constraints are so
strong there's no way that plane can go
down or even be disrupted and we need we
need an emulator we need to train our
people we need to have the kind of
confidence that when they when they're
making a change to the networking really
people people's lives and work depend on
it that it's going to work and so we we
need a something like a flight simulator
so we built one and I will tell you a
little bit about it and this is the
open-source thing that you can consume
starting in January you can simulate a
network with with fidelity you won't be
able to tell if it you can bring in your
network engineer and let them go at it
and give them a kind of a Turing test is
this the emulator is this the real thing
they won't know you can do that with
with thousands of devices in minutes
it's seamless it's easy to deploy and
it's like again high fidelity so just
you know do we do we use it we spent
twelve million core arrows on Azure
network emulator before I came here we
were running it for a big network
migration that we had to do
so by the way because of this emulator
and the confidence it gave us we did
more Network migrations we changed
everything in our network we moved what
we pulled more cables we changed more
routers and switches we did more stuff
to the network in the last year than
we've ever done before and it was
probably the biggest network migration
in anybody's history and nobody noticed
but we caught one hundred or so bugs in
this emulator and that's why nobody
noticed the bugs never got their
production so you know the way it works
is a network engineer describes a change
in a machine readable form we
automatically you know we could pick the
what vendor software we want it's it's
the actual vendor software and our own
software then we download it into a into
the emulated replica and run it we also
use their improving technology from them
MSR as well as the emulation and we find
out if the intent worked as we expected
intend to change so let me try to click
through this I don't have time to
simulate myself ok so one one problem
you have with but you know these these
simulations is you know how big a
network to emulate are you gonna you
know where is the boundary are you going
to go for the whole internet you know
where do you draw the line do you have
to do the whole data center well you
need this fidelity you need to be able
to answer the question that you know is
this change safe is it gonna have the
intended impact so part of the the
research on this had been how do I draw
the smallest boundary so I can answer
the question without emulating the
entire internet and that's what we do so
we we picked the an economic frontier
and emulate inside it and we do that all
the time and that's that's described in
an SOS P paper
from this year okay let me say one other
thing about it so again I wanted to tell
you how high fidelity it is you know if
you imagine like you're you're an
engineer at one of these device
companies and you don't you don't expect
your your your software to sort of go to
sleep and wake up in the cloud and still
work you know it expects hey you know
I'm a device and I've got these wires
and I'm gonna check the health of those
wires and I'll run some Diagnostics it
all that has to work it it it has that
software cannot has to be faked out and
fooled and understand that the the the
the the emulated hardware is it's just
like you know the the real hardware and
that that's what happens here so that's
part of the interesting engineering
problems why does that work it's because
of the cloud is because of virtual
machines same deal with virtual machines
virtual machines think they're on real
machines is because of virtual
networking so we had to figure out all
that tech that's why it works now it
didn't work five years ago or ten years
ago we have the the mechanisms because
we can virtualize everything to full
fidelity in the cloud we can also
virtualize the networks and do this
emulator and then use the cloud to run
on the emulator that's why it works so
again try it you'll be able to you can
email the developers now to get early
information about it and it'll be on on
the on Azure marketplace so this is an
open invitation for all the work try-try
sonic try the emulator alright
I think the appendix which I'm not going
to get to has to do with all those other
projects I don't have time for but I
it's it's really an exciting opportunity
to to rethink the the basics of
networking I I don't know how to
directly or somehow chemically or this
really convince you that reliability is
the the most cool thing to work on the
most important thing to work on but if
you start to think about you know
changing all of computing to run on the
cloud and then just you know recurse on
that and think of what does that mean
what what all the startups all the oh
they already started ups all the you
know all the work that you see pouring
in the cloud all the AI and machine
learning then you'll see that you know
reliability is really a hard problem and
deep and takes years of work and and and
you know we need you to help us get
there all right I'll wrap it up thanks
right thanks well that's just thank you
again Alberta it's amazing when you
consider the scale of challenge as an
opportunity and networking that you're
representing today and hopefully that
gives you some potentially interesting
pointers to how to pursue your own
research and as well as to guide
research and instruction for your
students so we are at the end of day one
thank you for a fabulous day I hope it
was worthwhile I hope you enjoyed it
just take a moment before we head off to
what I expect would be a really nice
dinner tonight at the hotel I want to
give you a little bit of a recap of what
we've done in a preview of what will
happen tomorrow so I was really happy
that we were able to announce here for
the first time today and to give you
input to some new fellowship
opportunities both the student
fellowship as well as invite your input
to the young faculty fellowships which
we'll be bringing back soon I
appreciated the fact that Albert was pre
announcing for you all the open
network emulator one that'll be
available in January and hopefully you
caught the email address if you'd like
to get a hold of that ahead of time we
had a lot of really top-notch plenary
and breakout sessions today I was super
pleased with those and again thanks to
all of the people who prepared so well
to deliver on that I hope you had an
opportunity to enjoy some break time
into network both with old friends and
to make some new friends so we have more
of this to come again tomorrow tomorrow
we'll be doing much the same we have a
one interesting thing though that we
will add to tomorrow we have a
technology showcase which is actually
going to be across the hallway tomorrow
it's a bit of a poster session this show
directly some of our researchers and the
projects that they're working on gives
you an opportunity to engage directly
with them we'll introduce you to those
very broadly in what we call a lightning
round we'll have them come up and give
you just a one-minute overview so you
can get both the breadth of what we're
doing as well as have the opportunity to
engage deeply with the researchers and
the projects that we highlight there
tonight I'm looking forward to joining
you all at dinner Harry Shum will be
there eric Horvitz of course will be
hosting there will be a bag check at the
hotel so when you get there if you're or
you're not staying at the hotel you just
want to use a bag check there's a bag
check their buses we'll be out front
we've got a couple of buses that are
specially marked that have a trivia
contest on them so if you particularly
want to or don't want to be doing trivia
on the ride home I had two jobs as I
said one of which was the weather which
I'm hopeful is still going well out
there the other was traffic I'm still
working on that but maybe Albert can
help me with some of the traffic
management that we have to do but I am
looking forward to dinner tonight we'll
hopefully have you as well for a group
photo tonight so it'll be a lot of fun
one other way I'd love for us to be able
to say thank you to you is when you do
check in we'd love to provide you with a
new smart speaker so we've got the
Harman Kardon invoke plus Cortana
speaker as a gift for you all so thank
you again for joining us here today the
buses are out front we will be back here
at 8:30 in the morning if you enjoyed
what you heard today be sure to
communicate with us on all of those
properties hashtag is MMS facts um we'll
see you at dinner tonight
and here again tomorrow morning at 8:30
thanks for a great first day
[Applause]